[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zu sein heute gibt
es ein richtig leckeres rezept und dann
auch noch und schnelle fritz denn ich
werde desto papa machen also pasta
kaffee nudeln mit einer roten pedro
sauce mit mini mozzarella und
kirschtomaten und für finde immer ganz
gut und ganz schnell zubereiten denn
roth fest so habe ich immer ganz gerne
im kühlschrank auf vorrat und im prinzip
ist dieses rezept dann wirklich super
schnell hergestellt denn das rote pesto
und vermengt mit den restlichen blut
haben und habe innerhalb von 10 bis 15
minuten das perfekte gesicht
ich zeige euch mal die zu treffen dafür
brauche ich 50 gramm pinienkerne werde
ich 100 gramm pedro de vries gemacht 300
gramm nudeln ich habe 200 familie
mozzarella welt in 100 gramm
kirschtomaten zehn bis zwölf
basilikumblätter und zum bestreuen fc st
ganz wichtig ist dass ihr jetzt schon
bereits nudelwasser aufgekocht hat
deshalb in einem großen topf nudeln
aufwand da kommen noch 20 meter pro und
normalerweise so dass man nudeln zuletzt
gab denn diese wartet doch wie nudeln
und nicht umgekehrt aber das geht jetzt
so schnell dass ich jetzt schon die
nudeln abkochen kann
die vorstellung und verkocht nicht über
und dann kann ich in der zwischenzeit
nehmen hier in der pfanne schon mal die
pinienkerne
und ich schenke dir ohne fett bis sie
etwas farbe angenommen haben und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die
tomaten nehmen und viel halbiert
[Musik]
bei den phoenix die aufpassen dass nicht
verbrennen
und sobald die farbe angenommen haben
haben jetzt auch noch pech lopatta pro
da hab ich ja getrocknete tomaten mit
olivenöl viele kerne parmesankäse und da
hat man wirklich ganz viel geschmack mit
dabei die hitze fällige zinsen runter
und aufgewärmt werden
[Musik]
jetzt kommen die formaten mit rein und
den muss verein angeblich gleich ist mir
dazu dass wir nämlich nicht schmelzen
sondern alsfeld umgeformt bleiben
jetzt muss ich dem prinzip auf die
nudeln warten bis 16
[Musik]
aber jetzt minute und gäste und wer
dessen herz der frau ausmachen sehen
hier habe ich eben auch aus wenn minuten
haben einfach ein bisschen länger
gebraucht gibt ereignisse katharina
mitkommt und 17 nudelwasser mit fünf
lose verteilt sich besser um die nudel
herum
und an dieser stelle kann ich es auch
von demos for elephants hinzufügen
da kommen jetzt die passende kompletter
noch mit rein
und jetzt geht's los die nudeln abgießen
die nudeln hier mit rein das ist echt
cool die perfekte menge für zwei
personen
je nachdem wie viel wir noch verschärfen
aber umfragen zu personen jetzt nur noch
kurz umrühren und schon ist das gefährt
ab je länger man den mozzarella trifft
umso mehr schmilzt dann mache ich nicht
da bin habe ich das vergnügen das
anrichtet einfach noch entwickeln
parmesankäse privaten überregional auf
italien dann natürlich noch einen
basilikum platz
und werte
[Musik]
natürlich nicht
sennekamp die idee zu dem respekt habe
ich übrigens aus dem piano das ist doch
ein restaurant der restaurantkette da
war mir neulich im kanton auch in berlin
und da ich mit diesem konzept ausgesucht
und zwar wirklich super lecker aber ich
muss dazu sagen
der koch die kochen sofort den augen was
stellt dann hin und sucht ist das aus
finde ich sehr schön aber der koch die
kirschtomaten vergessen japan ihr sind
wir mit dabei und das rezept ist
wirklich super lecker und wie gesagt
auch ein sehr schnelles rezept
nachkochen wolf dallas - klopp der
interschutz noch mal ganz genau und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß und
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]